[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à
novossibirsk
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 3500 km à
l'est de moscou dans la troisième ville
de russie en plein coeur de la sibérie
voici la rivière robes l'une des
rivières les plus grandes du monde et au
loin vous voyez la voie ferroviaire qui
relie l'europe à l'asie via le célèbre
train le transsibérien
[Musique]
novossibirsk ville récente du haut de
sept cent trente bougies est devenue
l'une des plus grandes villes de sibérie
de par son activité commerciale
culturelle et scientifique son
développement rapide attire aujourd'hui
une population jeune et dynamique
ce carrefour des traditions orientales
et européennes est la ville où notre
héros s'est installée nous sommes
arrivés au théâtre de marionnettes
nous allons rencontrer roland beaudin
qui est le metteur en scène qui
aujourd'hui fait la répétition générale
de son spectacle cabot caboche allons
faire connaissance écoute roland c'est
magnifique merci de nous accueillir dans
son théâtre de marionnettes c'est super
moi je suis vraiment en pleine
admiration bravo ça fait plaisir
voyez couderc mais je m'attendais
vraiment pas à voir ça ici à eux aussi
bien ce qu'on te casses magnifique
comment ça va se passer aujourd'hui
parce que moi je veux tout voir je veux
tout savoir j'ai un terrain ton jeu il
faut que tu nous racontes tout alors où
est ce qu'on va là maintenant dit nous
alors là je vais te présenter la scène
principale du théâtre on va faire les
dernières prêterait répétition on doit
se souvenir avec les acteurs de ce qu'on
a fait ce qu'on doit corriger ont
travaillé un petit peu la lumière avec
ruth je suis impatient de voir tout ça
aller allons-y
merci
[Musique]
tu peux nous raconter un petit peu déjà
comment tu es arrivé là en fait dans ce
théâtre de marionnettes et qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça représente pour toi
aussi comment ça a commencé
c'est un venu un petit peu quand j'étais
un petit peu gamin j'ai fait quelques
inspecteurs humaniste quand j'étais à
l'école après j'étais grand fan un petit
peu de des guignols de l'info l'émission
très connu et qui est un petit peu donc
un somme un petit peu de ce qu'on peut
faire dans le sens montrer la vie mais
d'une manière un petit peu différente
ouais satiriques ou poétiques et moi
c'est ce qui m'a attiré parce que je
fais aussi du drame
ça permet de créer des mondes donc et ça
c'est aussi aux quelque chose pour les
enfants c'est aussi le l'espace du
compte et dans des univers un petit peu
plus large et un peu plus imagé redire
c'est ce qu'on faisait si bien que je
suis payé à rêver et à réaliser ses
rêves
donc ça c'est pas mal comme comme
définition du métier parce que j'ai
remarqué
tu n'y as su me trompe c'est en fait il
ya on regarde à la fois évidemment la
marionnette mais on regarde aussi
finalement l'acteur parce qu'il ya un
amateur le manipulateur d'accord qui
fait toutes les mimiques et en fait
c'est un mix des deux c'est ça oui donc
avant il doit par le passé on ne voyait
pas du tout l'acteur l'illusion
théâtrale est un petit peu brisé par le
cinéma
mais malgré tout elle les acteurs
deviennent une partie du jeu et les
magnetix contemporain
quasiment plus à cacher les acteurs et
donc on est passé à quelque chose de
plus théâtral où on inclut real inclut
l'acteur dans le jeu la force des métaux
et des acteurs de mettre en scène c'est
qu'on arrive à les rendre vivants et à y
croire même si on sait qu'il ya mathis
juste à côté à la base des objets et
toute la difficulté c'est de leur rendre
la vie et ça alors je te propose d'aller
faire une petite visite au musée par
être montré un petit peu certaines
marionnettes très bien après toi alors
dit moi un petit peu par rapport aux
européens est ce que les russes aiment
justement ce théâtre de marionnettes
alors ça fait partie de leur culture
aussi donc je pense qu'il ya un amour
partagé entre les européens et les
russes parce que c'est une tradition
européenne attendue mais effectivement
ça se tiennent les manettes et un petit
peu considérée comme donc la première
connaissance avec le théâtre et
effectivement c'est le lieu pour les
enfants
chaque ville à un tiers des malades sont
obligés qu'au maintien du lien théâtre
du drame mais il d'ailleurs un tir de
marne est obligatoirement sur rien c'est
pas quelque chose qui est considéré
comme de seconde zone
les prix nationaux il ya une catégorie
pour les marionnettes
c'est quelque chose de prestigieux parce
que tu peux me raconter un petit peu les
différents types de marionnettes qu'il y
a ici dans ce musée
[Musique]
danse théâtre on n'a plus les manettes
comme appel à tige c'est à dire que ce
remake à phil simplifiée d'accord on
tient une tige et puis on manipule les
mains avec quelques fils qui a là que
vous voyez un site s'il ya quelques
marionnettes mais effectivement là c'est
ce type de manette deviennent assez rare
qu'elles sont elles sont extrêmement
dures à montpellier il ya très peu de
gens parce que ça et réclame des heures
des heures et des heures de préparation
de d'entraînement alors l'une des
spécialités en russie je vous montrais
c'est ce qu'on appelle les manettes à 3
30 avril illégale pitt
comment je fais moi pour manipuler il
n'y a pas qu'à pas un endroit alors ici
on peut pas mais je vais te montrer un
endroit où on peut te via brax alors ici
on est à l'endroit les ateliers ou créer
les manettes on fabrique du début à la
fin et marne est c'est ça c'est un
modèle tout police et news oui alors je
peux te montre un peu brièvement
constamment il ya une petite bonne
manette ce qui permet de bouger le cool
le col a indiqué ge lassant et après là
il faut manipuler avec les deux mains ça
c'est une idée des plus dures à dire à
manipuler une des plus élégants sel peut
faire beaucoup de gestes
dire bonjour beaucoup de choses sont
possibles mais c'est ici que sont fait
toutes ces petites merveilles alors
celle là il ya des choses à l'intérieur
ça tourne ça tourne c'est cela le
n'ouvre pas la bouche par exemple elle
peut juste bouger la tête le cou et se
permet beaucoup de jeu de mouvement
j'essaie d'applaudir mais c'est pas
facile
oui alors ça demande beaucoup
d'entraînement ce n'est pas pour rien
que malheureusement il faut énormément
professionnels pour manipuler ces choses
là parce que c'est ça l'herbe des
simples mais c'est pas simple du tout ça
ça bouge comme ça ouais passe comme ça
et puis un petit gâchette ouais petites
choses qui permettent de bouger ça mais
c'est pas quelque chose que ces choses
qui commencent à disparaître un petit
peu ouais
ces mécanismes en général en france on
ne trouve quasiment pas je veux montrer
par exemple un manomètre keep in the
kills grande la construction du
mécanisme justement l'intérêt d'une
manette
je vais vous présenter un petit peu y
aura quelques y est le compositeur lui
il fait les squelettes et après elles
sont animées sont pas ainsi on le donne
des costumes et après maquillage les
cheveux les accessoires si nécessaire et
il y aura et notre spécialiste
constructeur sur une barrière qui est
vraiment quasiment un type unique c'est
un truc qui est fait sur sur les sur le
poignet si un point glisser çà et là tu
étais là et le corps est en bas et c'est
avec les doigts que tu m'as dit même
qu'il manipule le tout la highway system
comme ça et
les doigts ont par exemple c'est les
pattes on dire et là il manipule comme
ça avec elle les doigts qui sont des
raies qu'il soit unique et émana et et
c'est un travail d'orfèvre
il ya très peu de gens qui sont capables
de faire des choses comme ça il a
demandé que les langues de ses
marionnettes fonctionne voici la
maquette que j'ai fait tous ces chiens
ont des langues dans la pièce de roland
toutes les marionnettes sont totalement
mécanique elle semble vivante en volume
en fait nous utilisons rarement des
poupées entièrement mécanique
c'est la première fois que nous avons
une pièce comme celle ci c'est unique
donc depuis combien de temps tu es en
russie alors maintenant alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier et je suis
depuis 2015 manière permanente j'y vis
j'y travaille roland la trentaine bien
dépasser et nez à nez dance en
haute-savoie proche de la frontière
franco suisse
son père est français sa mère est
hollandaise la vie humaine d'abord
roland à marseille où il obtient son bac
de programmeurs mais à 24 ans passionné
par le cinéma
roland décide de changer sa profession
et il part à minsk en biélorussie où il
découvre le monde du théâtre de
marionnettes puis roland poursuit ses
études en russie à saint pétersbourg
mais il ne se voit pas encore lié sa vie
avec la russie et il regagne la france
où son chemin professionnel commence les
premières mises en scène les premiers
festivals merlan voulait un changement
radical laisse tous derrière lui et part
pour saint pétersbourg
relance fait rapidement remarquer en
russie pendant deux ans il est invité
sur différentes scènes en tant que
réalisateur
jusqu'à ce qu'on lui propose le poste de
directeur artistique d'un théâtre de
marionnettes akirov qu'il occupe pendant
deux ans
[Musique]
police qu'ils ont d'eux mêmes en 2019
rôle on reçoit une proposition de
travail à novossibirsk qu'il accepte
aussitôt et depuis ce temps là roland
profite à plein temps des plaisirs de
cette ville sibérienne
[Musique]
on s'habitue facilement à la russie moi
je pense qu'il ya un petit temps
d'adaptation
il y avait une blague bienvenue chez les
ch'tis on est parent on a un petit peu
on ira en pleurant et après on pleure
quand on veut repartir
c'est à dire que au départ ce n'était
pas simple puis après je ne peux plus
faire sans
j'ai voulu partir quand j'ai fait mes
études je vais retourner en france et le
froid me manquait et la chaleur des gens
de manquer et tous mes amis est rude et
les gens que j'avais connu ici mon
hockey et alors
ici j'ai pas vraiment jamais froid c'est
juste que effectivement parfois les
hivers peuvent être très longs l'hiver
le plus froid de ma vie a été à
marseille et travailler avec des russes
on peut travailler avec eux des heures
durant ils peuvent être allé à la limite
de la fatigue
et ça c'est par exemple des choses en
france par exemple à 5 heures où l'art
est en russie
en russie ils vont jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
sociaux nécessaires même ils peuvent pas
dormir pendant deux trois nuits mais ils
seront prêts ils feront tout ce qu'il
faut et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
agréable parce que heureusement là là
c'est pas toujours un truc de régulier
parfois il faut beaucoup d'énergie pour
arriver au résultat
donc tu par le russe maintenant on
vraiment je fais a mis du temps à la
pompe
c'était difficile si l'on étudié à
l'université j'aurais très mal après
j'imagine
là j'avais besoin d'apprendre le russe
pour étudier aussi
le théâtre est donc en six mois
six mois un an j'ai progressivement
assez rapidement les bases puis après le
minimum et tu viens d'installer in situ
vivien oui très bien je peux te montrer
sur écoute allons-y intéressant c'est
ici que je vis dans le logement que de
fonctions que me donnent de théâtre très
bien où je vis avec ma compagne avec ton
atelier c'est ça alors là c'est là où je
travaille un petit peu chez moi et où
mon ami travail un petit peu aux
manettes ça la scénographie ce sont ces
esquisses c'est ça
ses premières idées et après il ya les
dessins techniques qui sont justement
comment la structure de la marionnette
sera doit être fait côté la mécanique
je vois que tu as ramené de la compagnie
c'est ça oui alors ça c'est mon char ma
chatte ronnie que j'avais découvert que
j'avais pris en france et puis elle
m'accompagne et quand j'ai émigré
c'est une voyageuse elle a fait deux
fois l'aller-retour entre la france la
russie et elle a fait toute la route
depuis saint-pétersbourg en sibérie en
voiture avec moi je t'invite à boire un
petit café
ouais d'accord très bien tu te tuer des
jeux pas des petites anecdotes
qu'heureux correspondait peut-être pas
avec l'europe par exemple alors par
exemple luisante
alors ça c'est plus un fait général il
ya une grande différence par exemple
entre la perception des artistes en
russie et en france
en france c'est extrêmement difficile de
trouver un logement quand tu es
simplement comédiens ont considéré comme
pauvre et
pas fiable est donc très difficile à
cause d'une vie alors qu'ici comedia
c'est assez prestigieux donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup marqué et
qui a beaucoup influencé sur mon choix
de venir ici et raconte moi un petit peu
aussi s quand est ce que tu as des
hobbies en dehors de en dehors du
théâtre
ce que je sais pas qu'est ce que tu fais
peut-être de ton temps perdu à ces
derniers temps je sais beaucoup de
trouver du semis à la plongée il ya deux
trois ans malheureusement c'est sûr
qu'en sibérie c'est un peu difficile
j'ai quand même réussi cet été à faire
de la plongée dans un lac dans un lac de
sibérie ce que je ne pensais jamais de
ma vie faire de la plongée en sibérie
j'espère beaucoup faire cet hiver aller
dans l'altaï dire je suis de
haute-savoie j'ai fait beaucoup de ski
et j'aimerais beaucoup de refaire du ski
cet hiver et dans le domaine culturel
est ce que
je pense que si tu es dans le théâtre
que tu as toi-même voir juste pas des
opéras des ballets quelques opéras et
des liens très grand père ici j'imagine
que comme à moscou il y a le bal shui
je pense que y avoir à peu près la même
chose ici ça là ils ont même un opéra
qui encore plus gros kemboi vers celle
de l'opéra qui le plus grand du monde
place on qui est très très grand qui est
très riche
effectivement il faut une très belle
très belle maison siège était à portée
du camembert alors il est à remarquer de
normandie mais ça reste un camembert
russe
oui au cas où ça te manque oui alors
c'est chose qui est qu'est ce qui manque
le plus pour un français ça je dois m'en
tape et quelquefois sinon je déprime
voici la première représentation la
salle est déjà remplie sur scène la
pièce cabot caboche basé sur l'oeuvre de
l'écrivain français daniel pennac
l'histoire d'un chien errant et de ses
aventures amical à la fin nous avons
récolté les impressions des petits comme
des grands ainsi que de ses collègues
et voici ce qui s'est dit roland est
toujours plongée dans son métier il
pense toujours au spectacle spectacle et
sa vision de la scène du spectacle
différent c'est un théâtre qu'on peut
qualifier de synthétique
il n'y a pas que des marionnettes sur
scène mais aussi des objets et des gens
et plusieurs systèmes de marionnettes
différentes
c'est bien sûr ce qui m'a en premier à
tirer dans les oeuvres de rollon mais
bien sûr sa mentalité est différente on
le voit dans la tradition des mises en
scène des dialogues voix et des mises en
scène en général
[Musique]
honda yoichi wada soit beau il donne
beaucoup de liberté de liberté d'action
il est toujours ouvert à nos idées qu'il
intègre dans le spectacle le jeu des
acteurs
ils y mettent toutes leurs hommes j'ai
été parfois émue aux larmes tellement
j'avais de pitié pour cabo catoche j'ai
bien aimé le héros principal
c'est intéressant qu'est ce qui lui
arrivera ensuite
en chine la boîte et travaille de
manière très détaillée
ces remarques sont très précises mais
les émotions
c'est ce qu'ils exigent des acteurs il
ya quelque chose de spécial un style
unique de communication avec le metteur
en scène
[Musique]
alors roland qu'elle était l'image que
tu avais en tête de la russie avant de
venir très inquiétante
très inquiet dans un peu ex-yougoslavie
maintenant basse et des gens très
intéressants les gens très stylé salue
les français ne savent pas des femmes
très très bien habillée très classe
alors un trait de caractère des russes
qui te plaît donc facilité à devenir
très proche qui n'est pas feinte
c'est à dire que si on est un ami on est
vraiment amis on peut le devenir très
vite un trait de caractère qui leur
manque
selon toi voilà ils sont très capables
de faire tout génialement la dernière
minute mais c'est un peu les rois de la
procrastination
on dira t'on endroits préférés en russie
au saint pétersbourg un plat ou la
nourriture qui te manque de la france ah
oui alors là il y en a beaucoup
effectivement c'est c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie qu'est-ce
que tu ramènerait de novossibirsk
mais beaucoup de souvenirs je prends sur
la nature ok alors maintenance avait des
questions j'ai besoin t'auras de réponse
tu choisis ça va être très rapide
d'accord alors 20 ou votre cas foie gras
ou caviar caviar est alors la question
la plus difficile puisque tu viens de
savoie effectivement creuser savoyards
ou les fameux pelmeni syberia les
pelmeni merci
et voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous avez passé un
excellent moment à novossibirsk avec
notre invité roland beaudin
je vous dis à bientôt à la prochaine sur
rt france
[Musique]